desde el 1 de enero de 2023 todos los
trabajadores del sector formal en México
gozarán de 12 días de vacaciones al
cumplir el primer año de trabajo Esto
fue posible gracias a una modificación a
dos artículos de la Ley Federal del
Trabajo que así lo establecen y precisan
que se añadirán dos días de vacaciones
por cada año subsecuente laboral así
hasta llegar a 20 días y a partir del
sexto año de trabajo Se añadirán dos
días de vacaciones por cada cinco años
de servicio esta iniciativa fue una
propuesta original del partido
movimiento ciudadano y que después fue
enriquecida por los partidos del trabajo
y el partido Morena si bien fue aprobado
desde el 3 de noviembre en el senado en
la cámara de diputados pretendieron
modificarla para que no necesariamente
tuvieran que disfrutarse los 12 días de
manera continua el senado sin embargo
advirtió que no aceptaría estos cambios
por lo que a final de cuentas quedó
aprobado como originalmente estaba
planteado el presidente López Obrador
dijo que ya firmó el decreto por lo que
entrará en vigor conforme a lo
establecido esta iniciativa pretende
apegarse a lo sugerido por la
organización internacional de trabajo
que pretende que sea un piso mínimo de
18 días si bien Aún está lejos con estos
12 días representa un avance pues
durante 50 años no hubo modificaciones a
la ley y los trabajadores únicamente
gozaban de seis días de vacaciones al
contar con su primer año de trabajo
López Obrador también dijo que es
necesario un periodo suficiente de
descanso y que además esto redundará en
una mayor productividad para las
empresas